[Music]
welcome to the McMillan report I'm
Marilyn wils your host and our guest is
Frederick weary a professor of Sociology
he is an economic and cultural
sociologist who toggles between domestic
and Global investigations of money value
and social life he has published five
books and a four volume encyclopedia
today we'll talk with Professor weie
about his new book Money Talks
explaining how money really works
welcome Professor weie thanks for having
me let's begin with an overview of your
book tell us about it well it is a
collaborative effort uh the other two
editors of the volume are Nina bandel at
the University of California Irvine uh
and Vivian ziser at Princeton and what
we did was we looked for people who were
leaders in their fields uh in sociology
economics political science anthropology
and law uh and these were people who are
asking questions about what is money and
how are people using it okay uh and
they're asking um questions that defy
the typical understandings of uh what
money means in the lives of Ordinary
People such as what
uh so one of the things that that we ask
is uh when people are making decisions
about uh when to take on debt uh when to
save when to spend um how are they doing
it and one of the the core um uh
findings uh across the chapters is the
importance of social relationships moral
evaluations and institutions and so we
have some chapters that uh that explore
this at the household level and others
that go up to the corporate level and so
even the way that uh corporate entities
do their budgeting relies on both
understandings of tradition uh and
social relationships and and that I
think is a strange finding for some okay
so what was a catalst for the book what
led you to write it um so uh and I know
actually it's a volume it's a collection
of um papers yes yes and so um uh Nina
bandal and I had had been in
conversation about work that we were
doing on separate projects um and she
had been doing some work on foreign
direct Investments and now had moved to
investigations of uh why people uh uh do
their charitable givings in the way that
they do uh and I had uh started engaging
with uh uh people doing Innovative work
in financial services and thinking about
how to include more people in an
equitable way in the financial system
and so as we were help trying to help
each other through some of our puzzles
uh we kept going back to to the social
meeting of money which was one of the
common touchstones for us um and the and
and and then we reached out to the
editor I mean to the author of the
social meeting of money Viviana ziser
who had been our adviser in graduate
school H and we said look we we were
thinking about sort of having a
gathering of people who were doing this
work across different disciplines um we
were thinking about calling it money
talks and had reached out to the law
school here and and had Daniel marovitz
come in as a co-convenor for the G
Gathering and as we described the
meeting uh to vivana she then uh sort of
went looking through her folders as she
said you won't believe this uh but she
had a vanilla folder um in which she and
the late Chuck Tilly had uh come up with
a similar idea to have a similar type of
convening and it had some of the same
names that we had listed in terms of
people to be involved in the Gathering
in the volume and while I'm not a
suspicious person I am responsive to
Serendipity right right okay interesting
so let's talk about um what you mean by
the social aspects of money help us
understand what you mean by that yeah so
um when we think about something being
social we mean that uh when people are
using money they're necessarily taking
account of others we also mean that
money itself has a social life um if you
think about it money goes by a number of
different names and nicknames um even in
the way that we think about how we
budget our money we talk about our the
the college money that's the gas money
there's grocery money and by virtue of
having these different names we attach
different rules to it and so money is
not just the mathematical um entity in
which we make tradeoffs based on the
math but we're actually making tradeoffs
based on a whole set of meanings that we
assign to these categories uh the other
thing too that we sometimes forget is
that money also finds itself bumping up
against moral limits um and so there are
some things that we say money should not
buy even if there are some good re
reasons why uh putting some things into
sort of a price-based uh Market uh may
help sort of in terms of with clearance
and so so we see sort of all these
different social aspects of money even
in its Aesthetics and sometimes even the
way that the money is designed can be
polarizing in some countries or as a
form of uh bringing uh people together
and generating a sense of solidarity and
so and all these different ways we think
about money as social and also money as
an instrument that we're using when we
are affirming our relationships with
others and sometimes when we're ending a
relationship okay um interesting I know
you wrote one of the chapters in the
book let's talk a little bit about that
yeah so the chapter I wrote wanted to
draw attention to these um moments in
which the way we use our money um it's
public um it's typically in these
moments in which people are making life
Transitions and so uh you could imagine
you have a child uh who just finished is
finishing High School uh whether or not
you celebrate graduation the child will
have the credential and yet you have a
number of families who during these sort
of Life transition moments and also at
the at the time of death and going into
afterlife there's a sense that money has
to be spent um and the family will
prioritize that spending even at very
high cost of themselves even when
they're told this makes no sense right
uh and so one of the things that we that
I demonstrated in that chapter is the
existing work that looks at how we make
U how we place a lot of moral weight on
these transition points um and the
extent to which sometimes what should
look like a choice and look as if we
have a menu of choices those choices
begin to collapse and and so that
chapter is meant to uh bring in sort of
some of the empirical ways in which we
see the menu of choices collapsing by
virtue of the weight that's given to a
life transition and so let's talk about
the me method ology how did you get at
um you know looking at those choices or
perhaps lack of choices yeah so uh so
there so there are two ways um uh so in
that particular chapter I both relied on
some existing work um in which uh they
conduct its some experiments um and in
the experiments you're both basically
told that um a a particular outcome um
led to a moral good or a moral bad um
and then you're asking people to reason
through those outcomes
and by virtu they reason through the
outcome you start seeing that
um they have trouble differentiating
between the choice that they made um and
whether or not the choice led to this
this moral bad um and so there are
sometimes there are these moments in
which uh the outcome you should be able
to separate it out um and say oh you
know
actually that okay that's yeah that
experiments complicated let me move to a
different SP okay uh a a different way
that we we do this is uh through
interviews um and so in an interview you
can um set up a set of scenarios um and
then ask people um us why they made a
decision um and why they almost made a
decision and so one of the ways that we
really see how morality works is in
those moments in which uh someone is
very close to saying a yes or a no but
they uh then choose to do otherwise um
and that's where they have to offer an
account of you know why did I make the
decision that I did um and so that's one
of the ways that we qualitatively try to
assess um how morality is working itself
out in in a in a monetary decision right
right that's interesting I know money
has significantly changed over the past
few decades in terms of you know a lot
of people don't use cash anymore
everything is credit card based in fact
in some places you can only use a credit
card to to pay for things um in your
book you do look at the new technology
around money um I'm wondering if Bitcoin
is a part of that as well so talk a
little bit about the the new money I'll
call it yes the new money and so so we
have several authors uh Nigel do and
Bill Mau in particular who are very
concerned with these new monies um and
one of the things that they uh
particularly Nigel uh make a strong
Claim about is is and the future of
money is not tied to the state and so we
often think about sort of States as
issuing coin right and and legal tender
and in the future of money a lot of it's
electronic um and and coming out of the
private sector um the other thing too
that they note is um even though you
would think that because Bitcoin you
know it's a it's ones and zeros
um it should be free of some of our
social concerns and social markings and
yet people are still trying to mark it
up so even with an electronic currency
they're putting in little hashtags and
they're they're making little drawings
in addition to placing memos on some of
their transfers and so for some reason
we have this tendency to want to kind of
Mark why we're doing the things that
we're doing with our money even when
it's on an electronic platform the other
thing too that they note is the extent
to which some of these alternative uh
payment systems help us to do better
sharing together um so we can split up a
bill with friends on our vinmo um or we
can uh do a peer-to-peer lending
platform and remain in touch and affirm
our commitment to other people by virtue
of how we transfer um and the kind of
tags we place on those transfers and so
I think the future of money is one in
which sociability will come back in it
especially in these electronic uh
platforms as a way of helping people to
affirm why they're doing it um and and
maintaining a sense of commitment um as
they uh decide they're going to offer
give a loan to a friend um or split up
some payments right right so uh what do
you conclude in your book oh so one of
the things that we conclude is that the
thing that we don't do enough of um is
uh I pay attention to how when people
are using money they're trying to um
generate a sense of belonging um with
others uh and they're working on their
relationships and one of the the
mistakes we make is when we think about
people as users of money as individuals
who are not tied to other individuals
and so part of what the book does is it
pushes for this radical rethink of the
economic actor as as a as not just an
individual but a set of diads in which
you're constantly tied to others and
you're constantly negotiating what your
use of a particular um form of money
will do to those ties um and so it's
sort of a
a uh an insistence um on the centrality
of relationships um and monetary
management okay I'm curious do you also
look at people's um how people perceive
themselves and their self selfworth
through money the more money I have the
more successful I am or the less money I
have the least successful I am do you
look at that kind of thing um the so
what we do instead is uh is we have a
moment at which we ask uh for people who
have who feel as if they have lots of
money sort um how do they use it um what
do they do uh in terms of charitable
giving okay um and when they're making
decisions about charitable giving um how
are they uh why are they going to uh
privilege uh something like like the
American Cancer Society over a different
type of uh of um uh charity um and one
of the things that we find is when you
have a sense of um cancer for example it
happened to someone I know particularly
a family member um across gender you get
uh more of a commitment to to supporting
those kinds of causes uh particularly
when that's compared with a different um
charity in which there is not a sense of
someone I know someone close to me has
or could easily U be confronted with
that particular type of problem and so
even the ways in which we are imagining
um er the good that the money does uh
we're doing that also through our
relationship okay and then I know you
are working on a new project why don't
you to tell us a little bit about it and
does this one tie into it at all uh yes
yes uh so so um I'm working on these two
new projects that are very closely tied
um there's the one project in which we
are investigating um rotating savings
and Credit associations that have been
now formalized and they are now these
what what are called lending circles um
and it's an innovation out at the
mission asset Fund in the Bay Area and
what they did essentially is they said
that a lot of people uh responsibly use
money and credit but they just don't get
credit for it and these are people who
are using a lot of these informal
Financial Services um a lot of them in
the Immigrant community and what they
wanted to do was find a way to make
those practices visible and to affirm
positive uh Financial practices that
were happening under the radar okay and
they did this by partnering with uh both
City Bank for helping them to uh run
these lending circles electronically um
and with three credit agencies reporting
agencies and so what then happens is
people who were no who weren't in the
financial uh system at all showing up
with their credit score or those with
very weak scores found themselves
getting these positive pays for ontime
payments on a social loan okay and they
also felt comfortable uh engaging in
these particular Financial Services by
virtue of the fact that they said this
is something that I saw my parents doing
and it just all they had to do was
affirm it and formalize it and so one of
the things that that we're doing with
the Miss asset fund is where where we've
been able to ask a lot of questions of
their clients and sort of follow their
staff people around and just ask so what
ises it mean to have um an affirming
experience when using money an affirming
experience uh When developing credit um
the other thing that I'm uh and so we're
so we we've uh completed phase one of
that project uh finishing one book
project called Financial citizenship uh
with my collaborators one at Michigan
Kristen sefelt and the other one at
Cal State Fullerton Anthony Alvarez the
other thing that I'm doing is um
thinking about Bank Society relations in
general um and so a lot of the ways in
which people engage in their daily
rounds in social life is by using
various types of payment apps and all
sorts of financial services venmo for
instance like venmo for instance and so
one of the things we want to ask is how
are Bank Society relations changing
across the globe and so last November I
was out in um Argentina uh with the
colleague there Ariel wilkas and we were
running around doing field work and
these really marginal areas on the edge
of the city um the equivalent of what
they call in Brazil fabas um and we were
looking at these social branches of
banks um and uh talking to people who
were using those branches and also
talking to community groups who had
advocated to get these branches brought
to their Community what do you mean by
social branches so by social branches we
mean that these areas that were
considered dangerous okay lwi income and
therefore the bank instead of opening up
a uh their a regular Branch okay they
would open up a social branch in which
uh part of the branch of the bank's
mission was to engage in education with
the people in the area about this is how
you use a bank and okay and I actually
had a really um heartwarming moment of
watching one of the guards um who you
know who was regulating how many people
were coming in to use an ATM machine but
he also noted that he was a financial
educator because a lot of these people
they didn't know how to use the the bank
machine and so he would give them advice
about how to use machine would tell them
who to talk to upstairs in the bank for
other types of services and he said I
really love this job because I'm not
just a guard I'm actually helping people
and so you have these really wonderful
experiences in which people see the
presence of a bank as a way of saying
you to are part of society and somehow
the absence of any banking services was
a way of saying you don't belong and
there's no way of getting a sense of
belonging um and so I think one of the
things that we take for granted is the
extent to which banks and financial
services really do matter when you're
thinking about having a sense of being
assimilated into a society um and when
you think about what the mainstream has
we always talk about the mainstream and
if you don't have a bank if you don't
have basic Financial
Services then you're not in the you're
not even close to the mainstream and you
have hopes for it right interesting
thank you so much for being here with us
today and sharing some of your work yeah
thank you for more information about
Professor weary and his research please
visit our website at McMillan report.
yale.edu be sure to join us again for
another episode of the McMillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty McMillan Center for
international and area studies at
Yale
[Music]